mais attendez, laissez-moi lentement vous expliquer quelque chose,
je ne suis PAS mr.  Lebowski,
je suis le mec que vous connaissez ou de son
mec mademoiselle ou Deuter ou vous savez el
duderino si vous n'êtes pas dans la
brièveté, insinuez-vous mr.
Lebowski a employé comme sexe mr.  Lebowski
est-ce ta seule pièce d'identité tu t'es trompé de
gars Je suis le mec de ton nom Lebowski
Lebowski Jeff Lebowski l'autre
clé des décrocheurs le millionnaire J'ai reçu
cette note de rançon ce matin son perdant
débile mec ils veulent que tu prennes l'
argent et frappe son coursier  ouais mes sous-
vêtements sales mec le blanc enlevons
ça pourquoi devrions-nous nous contenter de 20
verts alors que nous pouvons garder le
million de millions entier mélangé dans tout cela en
jouant un côté contre l'autre au
lit avec tout le monde les souffle hein
des trucs fabuleux sur quoi qui est assis  un
million de dollars nous voulons de l'argent
ah assis dans le coffre de notre voiture où est
mon [ __ ] d'argent ils font où est ta voiture
qui a tes sous-vêtements
Walter c'est un cas très compliqué modulo
beaucoup de sorties sauvages est-ce ici devoirs
Larry et j'étais comme  mes sous-vêtements bandent
beaucoup de mèches euh à garder dans ma tête mec
bien attention mec est une boisson ici
j'aime ton style mec je n'ai pas d'autre choix
que de dire à ces clochards de faire tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour récupérer le  leur argent de
vous ils étaient des nazis mec ils étaient
nihilus mec ils n'arrêtaient pas de dire qu'ils ne
croyaient en rien
moi c'est
ma robe je jette des cailloux ce soir médaille d'
or à Jésus
ça pourrait être beaucoup plus complexe je veux dire
ce n'est pas juste ce n'est peut être pas
aussi simple